there is no best Viewpoint and that best
Viewpoint is subject to the question we
should not say this is the way to look
at it everything else is bad and so on
so forth contradictory sounding views
are sometimes necessary to understand
the subject openness and the fact that
Duality shows us that multitude of
attitudes and Views is important to
appreciate and connect not only in a
scientific context but in a broader
human societal aspect I think would have
a good application welcome everybody to
this edition of the into the impossible
podcast I am your fearful host Brian
keing and today it is a great pleasure a
treat in fact for me to welcome none
other than Camron vafa of Harvard
University how are you Camron thank you
very much Brian for having me in your
program it's a great pleasure I'm fine
and uh looking forward to our
discussions yes I've been uh just
devouring your book which we're going to
talk a lot about today puzzles to
unravel the universe and I've been
fascinated with puzzles my whole life
mostly my inability to solve them uh but
you are noted for having made tremendous
contributions to the world of
theoretical physics and this is your
first popular science book as I
understand it and I always like to say
there's a piece of advice that you never
should judge a book by its cover but on
this on this book not only do you have a
very mysterious and and puzzling imagery
uh but you also have endorsements in
comia from none other than Edward
Whitten who I've tried to get on the
show unsuccessfully but I I'll talk to
you about that later uh and also Brian
Green another Brian actually my kid's
favorite Brian in astrophysics uh but I
want to ask you how did you come up with
the name of the book puzzles to unravel
the universe and how did you come up
with the artwork that so beautifully
Graces the cover of this book the title
I think was motivated by a course I'm
teaching uh for Harvard's freshman
called physics math and puzzles it's a
freshman seminar and uh so the book was
basically the was grown out of this
course and uh so I decided I was
thinking about what title to choose if I
had chosen physics math and puzzles it
sounded a little bit um maybe boring so
I thought maybe I should use some
elements of it without sounding too
academic and a bit more kind of exciting
in terms of applications to the real
world and so on so I thought that uh
which which involves actually the
motivation behind the whole course which
is the connections with the real world
so I thought unraveling uh the universe
through puzzles puzzles to unravel the
universe does Justice to what I wanted
to convey and U that's why I chose that
as far as the cover I got some help from
some some people were online but uh this
whole design and all that happened
during the pandemic so I decided uh uh
during the pandemic one thing I could do
is to finish this series of notes into a
book which I decided
to do and the self-publish it just to go
over get it quickly out and get it done
uh so that it people who may want to be
looking at it could could have a chance
to do it during the pandemic as well so
so it was done in a bit of a speedy way
at the end but um so that's that's what
it is but I'm very happy with the with
the the cover of the book as well as the
way the book came out yes it's very uh
intriguing and it matches the subject
matter as well uh I want to make a
distinction between Miss Mysteries and
puzzles and wonder if you do that as
well to me there's a difference between
a mystery and a puzzle and and I once
discussed this with Freeman Dyson who I
know you knew uh the late great Freeman
Dyson and it was that you know a puzzle
is something that could be solved maybe
I can't solve it because I'm not as
smart as you but uh a mystery might not
be solvable and I wonder do you make a
distinction between Mysteries versus
puzzles well in a sense uh puzzles
aspire to be Mysteries that's good
puzzles aspire to be like Mysteries
that's not quite solvable but gives you
an inspiration to new ideas so I view
puzzles always like that but I I I think
for example in the book I talk about the
Enigma of quantum mechanics I still view
it as a mysterious features that we
encounter even though we think we
understand quantum mechanics you know
the features of experimentation within
quantum mechanics are sterious still to
me and so that in that sense I agree we
haven't solved it or it's not solvable
at this point it might continue to be
mysterious or maybe it gets resolved in
a different form similar things happen
like black holes we have similar enigmas
about black hole and mysteries about
black hole puzzles are pieces which kind
of as I say try to get some features of
these mysteries in some little nuggets
of truth and you could kind of wrap your
mind around it and kind of understand it
at least so there's kind of there's a
distinction but there's this also this
relation they want to reinforce each
other other that is you're hoping that
the Mysteries become like puzzles that
you can solve that's the way I look at
it yeah I looked at uh puzzles I
remember the most famous One perhaps is
uh Rubik's Cube is a is a puzzle that I
became infatuated with as a kid and then
early 1980s I think it's just about 40
years old or maybe a little bit older
made by believe a Hungarian named Rubik
and we became fabulously wealthy and his
whole life is wrapped up in in this
particular uh Cube and and it's uh even
such to the point that he cannot really
sleep when he tries to solve it faster
than his previous record Etc there all
these competitions and he can't really
do it as well as other people could or
when he was a younger man he could solve
it even faster I wonder you know if you
look at your career is there a
particular puzzle or mystery that you're
most fascinated by among the many things
you just mentioned quantum mechanics
black holes uh later we'll get into
String Theory are there things that just
keep you up at night and that you won't
rest until you solve them or perhaps
make some contribution towards the
understanding of them good problems have
interesting reformulation in terms of
things we can understand clearly in
terms of the model that we are
approaching so there are many examples
that what comes to my mind the
computation of the entropy of the black
hole for example using ideas about how
you count the string theory degrees of
freedom in the using the geometry of
string compactification the work I did
with my collaborator and Stringer is an
example but there are many such things
and I don't think I would just pick one
particular ones I think even the some of
the papers that may not be as well
received or as well known in in general
I still might enjoy some of the posits
that I can encounter and to me uh it's
hard to calibrate it and organize it in
terms of the ranking of which one is
higher or lower in terms of interest to
me but even trivial sounding puzzles
could be interesting and I find
interesting so so many of the puzzles
that I discussed in the book on the face
of it might sound like okay so what it's
so simple what what you want to learn
but even those simple ones I I I kind of
think after even after I've solved it
and discussed it for 10,000 times I
still enjoy thinking about it so I think
it's like uh the aftertaste of the
puzzle is what uh what attracts me to to
thinking because it gives you a
springboard for other ideas it gives you
say oh maybe this thing means is a bit
more something else and you begin to
think so it might sound by itself kind
of like a boring statement but the
connections and what what else it might
relate to is what fascinates me yeah I
think it was uh that uh maybe it was
Albert Michaelson one of the I think he
was the first US Nobel Prize winner one
of the first Nobel Prize winners from
America and he said you know experiments
are like Puzzles to a kid and just like
a kid will do a puzzle even once he or
she has solved it he'll do it again or
she'll do it again because every time
they do it they get a little taste of
the thrill that they got when they
solved it the first time and I feel like
that as a as an experimentalist I wonder
though there are some puzzles and
Mysteries that are known to be
unsolvable I'll I'll say something like
um girdle's incompleteness theorem it's
it's known that mathematics of formal
mathematical system is is you know self-
inconsistent in a sense which is we know
that to be true we don't know why that's
true necessarily I often find that about
experimental physics as well that
experimental physicists such as myself
have this desire to know what is
scientific what is worth pursuing and
some people don't want to pursue things
like string theory I want to ask you
what do you decide is worthy of your
limited we all have limited attention
and time how do you know when a mystery
or puzzle is worth solving or may have
it be known that it's unsolved how do
you divide your time amongst these many
activities well I think that
uh that's part of having experience with
various problems that we encounter you
get the sense of what is doable and what
is not and that's the difference between
somebody who starts doing science at the
beginning like when I was a student and
now where I have seen many many problems
solved and some of them not being solved
and so on by seeing this through
different through different kinds of
projects and so on you get a sense of
what is do and what is practical so on
the one hand you know what is practical
what is doable on the other hand you
have a sense of what is important and
interesting so then you take an overlap
between these ideas see okay among the
ones which are potentially solvable
which ones are potentially more
interesting and impactful and then you
kind of based on that uh overlap you you
decide what projects to work on so so
that's usually how I I I go about doing
it so there could be many interesting
questions that I would love to do it but
I have no idea so therefore I wouldn't
try this
but on the other hand there are many
things like I could do immediately but
they sound like not that exciting or
impactful I won't waste my time with so
so there's kind of like a the
intermediate line where you kind of try
to do the most interesting thing you can
do uh and that combination of being able
to and interesting is what what needs to
be both for me to feel like it's a good
project so I was thinking as I read your
book and thinking back to a conversation
I had with Lenny suskin last week about
uh one of the most impressive characters
in his mind in history arist starus and
you mentioned arist starus as well in
the book towards the end and you talk
about the fact that arist starus had
these ideas about heliocentrism which we
now know to be true but could not be
proven because it was impossible to
measure for example The Parallax of of
stars at that time in fact it wasn't
proven The Parallax uh was not proven
until I believe the 1700s even after
Galileo and and yet galile had tools to
actually prove cernus was right and he
didn't use them instead he used other
methods which turned out to be wrong for
example his book The dialogue was
originally going to be titled on the
flux of the tides and he contended that
the tides on Earth's oceans were caused
by the motion of sloshing and revolution
and rotation of the earth not as we now
know from the gravitational influence of
the moon so he was overwhelmed by the
kind of notion that cernus was right so
so that he used incorrect evidence to uh
to justify and bolster the hypothesis uh
on the other hand you know uh G starkus
had the right idea and Lenny calls him
you know the most interesting scientist
perhaps in history uh because he had the
right idea but the technology wasn't
sufficient what do you say to people who
say String Theory um or studying the
properties of black hole
singularities um which we'll get to in a
minute as well what do you say to those
people that say it's not worth spending
any time on it because you can't falsify
The Singularity you can't falsify String
Theory it's uh so flexible it predicts
or accommodates way too many outcomes
how do you justify that um is there an
opportunity to appeal to Future
technology uh as in the case of Galileo
and arist starus future eventually
technology caught up and pro them right
U do you think the same thing will
happen with string theory and if not why
should we study it as you say Brian many
of the things about String Theory are at
the level of predictions theoretical
predictions that are very difficult to
experimentally check with our current
level of technology so so it's in some
sense a promise for the future so the
question would be as we say why should
we spend time on something that we
cannot check in our lifetime as correct
or incorrect and so forth if there were
no method to check our ideas then we
would have then I would have abandoned
doing string theapy for exactly that
reason however due to the interesting
interconnection of different ideas in
high energy theoretical physics you can
actually check ideas theoretically so
you can check validity of an idea from a
different perspective and come to a
conclusion whether that idea is correct
or false without experimentation
somewhat of course that would validates
the idea itself as being self-consistent
logically correct mathematically
consistent with whether or not that's
part of the explanation of our current
Universe we still have to wait but we
have seen so much encouraging results
from string theory in terms
consisten relation different pieces of
physics that we have discovered like
interaction what kind of forces are are
working there things about what happens
for cosmology what happens for black
holes we now know there are black holes
Al very clearly I mean there's no doubt
about them and the fact that these ey
ideas and String Theory come to get give
a self-consistent picture to many
aspects of them makes us believe in them
and like for example the prediction of
Hawking made about black holes the fact
that black holes have entropy despite
the fact that Einstein's uh equations
predicts that they are
unique uh his uh taking to account of
the quantum mechanics the work of
beckenstein and Hawking in particular
showed that now there must be some
degrees of freedom which are inside the
black hole there are some micro States
and the fact that string theory was able
to account for those degrees of freedom
at least in specific classes of black
holes it's already surprising and gives
us a confidence that the theory hangs
together the details about how it would
relate to our universe the can we
understand the electron has such and
such a mass and so on remains to be seen
But even now even now I will give you
one example we can make predictions
right now Trum String Theory which have
experimentally been
verified now these exper these
predictions are rather uh in a sense uh
you would say not as precise a
prediction but still is a prediction and
I will give you one example so for
example you take the electron and it has
a mass and if you compute the mass of
the electron in the fundamental units of
physics which is plank Mass it's a very
tiny mass in plank unit is something of
the order of 10 the minus I don't know
22 or 23 it's a very tiny number so we
say great do we have any prediction that
the electron Mass should have been this
small without knowing that there is an
electron and just by knowing that there
is electric
charge and by knowing that there is dark
energy in Universe you find the Bound
for the electron Mass you find that the
electron Mass electron Mass should be
bounded by 10 the minus one on the upper
Edge and it's above 10 the minus 31 on
the low so the the lower bound comes
from the conation of dark energy and the
upper bound comes from consideration of
what is called the weak gravity
conjecture that gravity is always the
weakest force in any any consistent
universe so putting these together you
find the range for the mass of the
electron and lo and behold 10 the minus
23 which is the mass of the electron is
bigger than 10us 31 and smaller than 10
the m so there are some predictions that
you can see not as precise as we
typically like in physics right I'm not
going to write a grant proposal right
exactly but still the idea that this is
has no falsifiable prediction is not
correct there are predictions that if
the electron Mass was somewhere outside
this regime you could have said okay
this is inconsistent with these ideas so
therefore there some Aris from I might I
might gently push back and say you know
there are considerations in your book
that you bring up from what's called
naturalness that uh that that you could
actually get the black entropy to within
a factor of Pi or so uh just based on
dimensional analysis so that doesn't
require my um you know any string
theoretics at all and you might also be
able to push back I might gently again
with respect that uh you know that
Weinberg made predictions about the you
know value of dark energy um independent
of the string landscape but then it was
eventually realized to accommodate that
you'd have to have something like a
landscape which we'll get into in the
Multiverse um so is it unique to string
theory or you know if my smart
undergraduate can derive it from her
considerations of dimensional analysis
does it really count as a prediction of
string theory or could it equally be
used by fery to say it's a type of
firming calculation okay so good
question so let's go back to the black
hole question you raised first of all
even there it's not clear uh because
consideration of uh Dimension analysis
you mentioned presupposes that we make
an assumption that the entropy of a
black hole is related to the area of the
black hole and naively we would have Sol
this related to this volume and that's
not true that was one of the surprising
predictions of Hawking so another
dimensional analysis would have giv you
a totally wrong answer if we just use
the the volume so you have to first
assume its area okay let's assume its
area why should we get the factor of one
quarter of the area measured in plank
units what should be one quarter we
don't know a PRI from that calculation
Hawkings calculation shows it does
string prediction not only gives you
that one quarter but actually gives you
an infinite further correction it said
this one quarter of area plus a
coefficient Times log of the area plus
another coefficient divided by the area
plus another coent infinite expansion in
the area so not only it gives you
Hawking's answer it gives you all the
possible corrections to it so it's not
something that Hawking did not calculate
so from string the we not only get the
leading term when the area is large but
subing correction when the area is not
huge so these sub reading Corrections
are shows you that there's a very clear
picture of how you derive these
statements and not just the overall
coefficient in front of the area term so
it hangs together it is non-trivial and
to me these are the kind of examples
that uh bolsters our confidence in
string theory and its validity and other
approaches people got Pride does not
give you something as concrete and as
precise as as we have seen in string
theory so thank you that's a very
masterfully explained actually uh came
away just now with a new appreciation of
the depth of the mysteriousness of that
particular puzzle so you're unifying
Mysteries and puzzles for me comeon uh
you're to be congratulated my thumbs
rather occupied right now holding up
good old Carl Sean but yours is free to
push that like button and don't forget
to subscribe it really helps us with the
algorithm now back to the episode so we
talk about unification and symmetry
later because I want to talk about
hacking uh puzzle solving later on do
you solve do you do Crossroad puzzles no
I
don't you know who does a lot of
Crossroad puzzles Marilyn Simons who's
the wife of your good friend Jim Simons
who I believe You' written papers with
uh not too long ago uh we'll get to that
in a little bit but I want to talk about
a conversation I had with Lenny last
week Lenny suskin your friend and Lenny
and I were talking about singularities
and I said to him uh imagine if uh you
get a note from God although he doesn't
believe in God so you'll have to take my
word for it I said to him imagine you
get a note and it says that um actually
there uh there are no singularities at
the center of black holes within the
Horizon it's just purely classical and
furthermore God gives you a note and it
says um the universe follows the kind of
cyclical Eon hypothesis of Sir Roger
Penrose who's been on the show many
times and or the uh or a bouncing
cosmology of my friend Paul steinhardt
and yours at Princeton who's been on the
show also many times I'll put link to
that and uh and so there are no there's
no Singularity needed whatsoever um why
why do we think that quantum mechanics
needs to be wedded to married to uh
gravity in those two cases to my mind
those are the only cases where I often
hear my fellow friends and physicists
theorists mostly uh they say well we
have to unite gravity with quantum
mechanics because of singularities well
what if there are no singularities would
you still say that we need to have a
theory of everything say in that way no
I wouldn't my problem with unifying
quantum theory and gravity is far beyond
even if there were no singularities I
would have thought that be saying like
could I have electrons which are quantum
but protons which are not to me it's
like that it's not because there are
different forces the gravity is one of
the forces you could say well how about
gauge forces be classical Quantum but
the other one be Quantum there's no
formulas in which that makes sense you
cannot talk about what is your formalism
are you talking about how do you
describe the physics in that context it
doesn't make sense
now you can treat classical gravity if
you assume the gravity is not dynamical
in other words if there's no graviton if
there's no more classically that
propagates but that's not the case we do
know that there are gravitational ways
for example so gravity is dynamical well
we don't know that there are gravitons
but well there's a there's a classical
wave I mean so there's the fact that the
wave comes there's no doubt so there's
there's something moving so that's what
I mean by dynamical in quantum mechanics
we call them made of graviton but
regardless there's something moving and
so the question is how do you describe
this moving wave in terms of classical
physics or quantum physics and so you
cannot say okay if an electron which is
quantum interacts with this classical
wave what does that mean so that doesn't
that that that is that is a conundrum I
don't think singularities is the reason
I believe gravity has to be described qu
mechanically however since you mentioned
the singularize of the black hole If the
gravity were just
classical then you might think oh okay
uh this bad and the singularities are
not not possible and therefore this
incomplete the theory and therefore one
way out would be yes quantum mechanics
resolves Singularity another resolution
might be as you say for example there
could be higher order terms in N sense
Theory which we have ignored and if you
put it back in maybe gets rid of
Singularity or something so to me the
nature of the singularity is not a
convincing explanation of the existence
of quantum descriptional gravity
thinking about the uh other property
that people associate with black holes
uh actually Lenny suggested that to him
the singularity is almost less
interesting than what he calls the
stretched Horizon um in some uh in some
fashion in his books H the black hole
War his battle with Stephen Hawking to
make the world safe for quantum
mechanics he claims The Horizon is much
more um is much more interesting from a
quantum mechanical perspective what do
you make about that is the Horizon of of
interest to those of us who are trying
to unify gravity with quantum mechanics
in a sense I I sympathize with that view
that somehow Universal aspects of black
hole seem to be correlated with the
properties of the Horizon so somehow
deep understanding of why and how that
quite how that works seems to be a big
piece of the puzzles of black holes we
know that the nature of the
singularities and the structure of them
changes by little assumptions that you
might make and so that's that's in some
sense unstable kind of a question but
the Horizon is robust somehow the
existence of the horizons and the
properties of the horizons and what do
we think about measurability or
immeasurability of horizon those are
more robust questions so I agree with
with that that Viewpoint and I had uh
Juan Mala who's another friend of yours
on on the show and we talked a lot about
um about wormholes and in fact humanly
traversable wormholes uh I want to get
your opinion on why do you think uh
someone as bright as Juan uh who you
referenc in the book uh why would he
spend his time on something which is you
know surely inaccessible for for quite
some time do you do you think this is a
fruitful use of his time I think
probably you asked him or you could ask
him but I think that the ideas of
warhold is just understanding Warhol is
to try to understand what we think about
quantum gravity can do H I don't think
he's necessarily thinking about science
fiction kind of warm Hol even though he
might even talk about those the
traversible ones but the idea of
studying warm holes I think it was
studied many many many decades ago but
even more recently in works that there
was for example Lenny and ju worked on
connection between Einstein Rosen pki
Rosen Paradox and Ein Rosen Bridge which
is this Wormhole geometry so the
connecting them and so forth shows that
certain things that might be
understanding whose understanding is in
riches connecting different parts of
physics perhaps motivates want to study
warhost more more vigorously
traversability whether we can send the
spaceship there this and that and so on
is at this point not not in the cards
for our universe we don't see that under
our understanding does not necessarily
lend to that direction but I think I
would not be deterred nor would I find
this more overwhelming reason to study
warm holes I think we should study them
regardless yeah his his response to me
on the podcast was that he he has
founded a fruitful way to understand
quantum mechanics and and um and
gravitational field so he views it as
fruitful and important um and and yet
there there are criticisms of the the
work on which that paper is based upon a
series of papers he's written on
wormholes and traversible wormholes in
that they rely on um uh results that are
uh are completely unproven and perhaps
unacceptable by your colleague and my
friend Lisa Randall and her colleague um
sundrum which are these you know
five-dimensional universes or they rely
on um you know Juan's major contribution
these ads uh CFT kind of dualities those
are things we we don't believe we live
in five dimensions and we don't believe
that we live in ads you if anything it
seems more likely after I read your book
uh that we live in a DS not ads um so
again these these questions of are they
just merely you know I I could also
point to a crossroad puzzle or Rubik's
Cube and say they're very challenging
you're very smart if you can solve them
my kids can solve them I can't solve
them I I I take apart the Rubik's Cube
it turns out you can put it back
together take it apart and no one will
know that you did it um although I joked
once cun I wonder if you'll you you'll
get this joke I said I I got to the
point where I could solve five sides of
the Rubik Cube but I just can't get the
six side right that's a good one so uh
but anyway getting back to this yeah I
mean five-dimensional random syndrome uh
you know background space times uh ads
where we don't live in an ads you um
again it just seems like higher order
adding on higher order speculation when
you know I just I it's it's hard to to
justify and I'm not saying that only as
an experimentalist there are
theoreticians that that will say the
same thing why don't they spend their
time working out you know calculating
some cross-sections or or or whatever I
I don't know what theorists do to be
honest with you but um but is it is it
not you know um kind of speculative to
study these things unless you feel like
you're learning about math and that's
important to learn about
five-dimensional uh SpaceTime and ads
CFT where do you stand on that let me
say instead of that specific one because
I think
let me just change your question a
little bit uh the questions are why do
we spend our time to on theoretical
questions which are not directly
relevant to our universe that's I think
you're giving that through examples of
for example five Dimensions or anti
Deiter space or this and that so I will
try to I will try to give you a
motivation for why how how how we come
about that so what do we know about our
universe well we know it's made of you
know particles electrons quarks photons
this and that and there forces with
between them great what do we know about
their forces well we know quite a bit we
know what is called the standard model
describes the forces between them the
standard model consists of various kind
of forces the electro weak forces the
strong forces and so on and within this
context we understand how these particle
interact with forces okay now you come
to asking why why do we have this
particle why do we have this force can
we have other kinds of forces could we
have so this is the begin of a question
could we have for example in our
universe instead of having this finite
number of gauge group billions of gluons
or billions of photons or why do you
have just one little Photon why do you
have only one strong force why do we
have much more in fact if you were to
write a random theory in four dimension
which is consistent with Quant of field
Theory with with Finance rules of
calculations and everything you would
naely say okay it could be like a guge
group with you know billions of blue on
and this and that and this many
particles and that many but no no no we
only see very few particles with very
few forces around why okay now you might
say well this is metaphysics I have no
idea why I don't care about it on the
other hand a lot of people have would
like to have a deeper understanding of
not only what are the forces and the
dictionary or or geography or gen
geology of the what are the particle
names and what not but why why do we
have so many few of them why do we have
why don't we have more exotic situations
and so on so that's that's a question
now I will give you a parallel question
within strength the for which we now
have an answer you start with asking
okay the situation we live in this with
all the particles and all that is very
complicated it's very messy can I
idealize it and the answer is yes you
can idealize it idealize you still can
be in four dimensions you can be almost
in flat space like the universe we live
in like mowy space but let's add some
ingredient which is not in our universe
and that inging the super symmetry
suppose I say I have a maximum amount of
super symmetry to simplify my task
subject to only the assumption that I
have some gauge forces around so what is
the maximum amount of super I can have
which gives me gauge forces like gluons
and so on that's what's called n equals
to four super symmetric theories in four
dimensions fine so you you restrict your
attention to that then you ask within
this class do I have any reason that the
number of blue ones finite now if you
don't include gravity in the discussion
it turns out you have no bounds you can
perfectly understand these theories and
you can have arbitr large number of
nuans in that
theory however if you include the
gravity it turns out that the group
choices are finite you cannot have
arbitrarily big group so it turns out
the rank of the group should be less
than or equal to 22 so out of an
infinite number of Poss possibility
somehow just including gravity questions
involving consistency of gravity mixing
with the rest fixes what are the
particle Spectrum in that theory and
what are the possible forces and so on
so that means the question of gravity in
that context shows us crucial pling
these questions so now you say well we
don't leave in super symmetrics Theory
so why do I care about this this proves
the concept that gravity can restrict
what are the possible content of the
forces that we see around us of course
we hope to extend these kind of
arguments to the universes like ours
which have less super symmetry or no
super Symmetry and that's but that proof
of concept is what motivates us that yes
perhaps the answer is good toy model is
a cherished approach in physics we
always start in saying let's study the
harmonic oscillator of this or that
that's a toy model the harmonic
oscillator really doesn't exist the
idealized one is only idealized thought
but we always do it that's physics the
physics precisely modeling so string
theor is is at at the worst case a model
of what our universe could look like and
so at the very very rudimentary form is
that you want to say okay a structure
which is like string theory how could it
potentially give a universe like our
universe and so that kind of Dr
supposition is very similar to the well-
honored tradition of harmonic oscillator
as toy models of certain physics concept
we want to understand is there anything
any observation or lack of observation
that would cause you to abandon String
Theory I think that abandoning is a
strong word for it for me I think for me
there's by now there's no sub if you
give me a theoretical substitute for
string theory which is better in some
way and has explained at least as much
as string theory has done then I would
abandon it uh but I nothing nothing like
this is in the cards I think uh we are
if we understand that there are some
obvious preditions of string theory
which are uh ruled out in some form then
we we go back I will go back and search
my my understanding of string theory and
perhaps we we we made a mistake somehow
with our understanding because I think
part of an issue is that we don't have a
complete formulation what string theory
is so we are kind of on a a difficult uh
platform to be that sure is string
theory right is string theory false to
do that you have to know exactly what
string is and we don't know that yet so
I would go back and check my
understanding of the subject and uh
correspondingly what about super
symmetry where would you say we are in
terms of your credulity or prior basy
and prior on
veracity of of super symmetry well I say
that my prior right now is the super
symmetry is not there in anywhere near
our energy scales and large hydron cider
but I would say that there's my high
prior with the sufficiently high energy
could be all the way to Clank energies
you might restore some super symmetry so
I think that super symmetry is in some
sense a good prior but I wouldn't say
that that's a necessary ingredient for
strength the we do have models in string
theory where no super symmetry arises
some people some of my colleagues I I
don't know why they kind of say super
symmetry is a prediction of string
theory I wouldn't go that far there are
models within String Theory which are
perfectly fine and have no super
symmetry I want to read this uh the
passage from the book towards the end
about gauge symmetry you say many
important properties of particle physics
involv what are called gauge symmetries
these involve somewhat different flavor
of the more familiar symmetries we see
all around us with regard to
translational symmetry you might say an
experiment performed and that two
different points should have the same
result with regard to gauge symmetry we
might say that the two different points
are essentially the same point what does
that mean and how do physicists use
gauge Theory or symmetry as sort of a
hack to solve puzzles so first of all
what is gaug symmetry gug symmetry is a
symmetry that you kind of want to delete
in a sense it's a very strange symmetry
so let me explain what that means an
example of it this discussed in that
same chapter that you mentioned in the
book suppose you have you talk about the
exchange rate let's say between the US
dollar and Euro you have some exchange
like you know whatever one one one one
Euro let's say is
$1.2 okay fine suppose the European
Union decides tomorrow to to change the
to change the units of their money and
they what used to be one Euro now
becomes 100 euros okay then the exchange
rate between the US dollar and the Euro
will change by a factor of 100 that's
what we call gate symmetry we will say
in this context there's a symmetry which
tells that rate has to get multipied by
a factor of 100 or divide by a factor of
100 appropriately is is it a deep fact
well it's just the renaming of what you
mean by your unit that's all so gate
symmetry is like that so it's a
redundancy of a definition it's not like
it's not a fundamental number there it's
just if you change your unit that number
changes that's all and so so gate
symmetry is is is a key to that
statement now why that should come up
with so much power in terms of
applicability in our universe is not
obvious why should our universe be made
of gauge forces and so forth why should
we dealing be dealing with forces in
that form and this that that requires a
further thought and that turns out to be
the basic statement is the is the
following is that if you look at
property called unitarity which is
needed for consistency of a quantum
theory which basically means the
probability of something happening is
one it turns out that the spin of light
particles is less than or equal to two
and so if you look at the bons with spin
less than or equal to two there are only
three choices two one and zero and spin
two is graviton and spin zero is like
hick particle and spin one is like a
gauge particle so the existence of gate
symmetry is needed to make spin one
Theory work so you cannot describe a
spin one particle without this
redundancy so just from this picture we
are forced to have this redundancy so I
would say that the notion is to trying
to make sense of a particle which has a
spin one forces us to consider gate
Symmetry and I was thinking about that
in the context I also talked about that
particular problem uh with Juan now the
and he uh he referred me also of course
to the original some of the original
work was uh by PM Milani and Eric
Weinstein on that a particular example
deriving uh G Maxwell's equations from
it I was wondering you know it's not so
often I'll get a chance to run an crazy
idea by someone as eminent as you Camron
but um could could we not also use an
example from language in other words as
as Shakespeare said aose by any other
name would smell as sweet is that
another example of a gauge
transformation and so is there anything
we could do with it I don't know if you
say gauging do I think I think that the
main thing is not that mention of that
symmetry but that that idea is needed
for spin one to make sense spin one
particles to make sense spin one masses
particles to make sense need that now
why need that we can understand we can
explain it in the context of partical
physics but by itself a redundancy and a
name should not be that important and in
some sense gate symmetry encoding
redundancy yeah I had a conversation
with n Chomsky about that as well you
know kind of what we call something and
in the words of Richard Fineman who
would say you know just because you know
the name of something doesn't mean you
know that thing and I want to get to
Fineman in just a little bit one of the
other delightful things about this book
and we're talking with Professor cin
Rafa Harvard University about his
wonderful new book puzzles to unlock uh
to unravel the universe which is uh just
quite spectacular
is is this notion that um that there are
sort of hacks and tricks that we can use
to to unravel certain puzzles but that
some puzzles by their nature um you know
have have this mysterious quality to
them and and one thing that you spend a
lot of time on which I'm very fascinated
by is is God and religion and I I'm I'm
a practicing uh Jew myself and I always
say I don't know if I believe in in God
but I believe in religion I think there
are things that we can that religion can
do and it's practiced uh properly that
can benefit a person's life the uh the
absence of working one day a week uh is
a very big thing in my life and it
contributes to my sanity the Sabbath
every day every week I don't work I
don't send emails I don't tweet I don't
text you know those are that's kind of a
commitment to a religion if not a God I
want to say ask you a few questions
about that some of the greatest Minds in
history um were religious Believers
Isaac Newton uh you mention in the book
um you don't men this aspect of him but
his his biggest uh accomplishment
according to him this is a man who came
up with the prinkipia invented calculus
uh the universal law of universal
gravitation he said his uh biggest
accomplishment was being Christlike in
other words that he he never married he
never had relationships with women in
that way and that way he dedicated his
life to pursuit of knowledge of course
he also practiced Alchemy and did other
things but um what can you say about the
role of religion in in in your life uh
in in this book um what does it mean to
you and and obviously you don't prze at
all but you seek a Harmon harmonization
a consilience between uh between
religion and and God it reminds me of
your former late great colleague there
Stephen J G what what can you say about
the role of religion in your life and
maybe even as a physicist if if that's
applicable well I I did not talk about
the role of religion in my life I try to
keep it out of the public view I keep
that completely private so I I would not
discuss that aspect but I would instead
say that religion and science are
neither contradictory nor reinforcing
each other in my view there are two
separate domains of thoughts or beliefs
and I just in that in the in that
chapter that book I try to explain why I
felt that trying to prove or disprove
the existence of God the religion and so
on is a futile task in the context of
Science and I try to also uh try to also
say also the opposite that if if
scientists feel that they can disprove
or say that religion is useless I also
discounted that too by giving counter
examples including the lat understanding
of proposal that universe may have come
from the beginning of of of some
primordial existence which something
Einstein refused to accept and called I
don't not know if it's how true the
statement is but myth Christian
mythology I'm not sure if that is what
actually happened but the main point is
that being motivated by religion is not
a necessarily a bad idea as the example
show Newton is another example on the
other hand you know some people do great
without religion people like Hawking and
so on were perfectly fine with doing
exploring their ideas completely free of
any such assumptions and they did great
work too so I I don't try to uh I don't
try to make a statement really about
what it should or shouldn't be and My
Views I don't I kep it to myself because
because I didn't feel I I have anything
to offer in terms of advice or anything
to anybody so I just said there's no
point me sharing what I feel should be
or shouldn't be but I think the
listening to other scientists that who
have felt strongly about it one way or
the other and seeing okay what does it
tell us about the role of science for
their life and for religion and science
how they mixed in their lives was useful
perhaps but then I also thought that it
would fit with my book because you know
it's a serious discussion you know
science and religion
the book I'm talking about puzzle sounds
like a very you know you know fun kind
of thing is a little less less less
serious so trying to bring those two
subjects a very serious subject with a
very casual topic puzzles I thought it'd
be an interesting combination I was
trying to bring puzzles to to lighten up
the mood so to speak that okay there are
these serious discussions but let's talk
about puzzles in this context and I
offered a few puzzles some of my
favorite puzzles are actually in that
chapter so so I think uh I I just use it
as a spring Bo for discussions really I
didn't want to offer anything specific
but I think I think the main thing I
wanted to convey that thing is we should
be tolerant of view points and that was
that was the that was basically I was
driving in that chapter yeah we hear a
lot about the hostility of science to
religion I always point out that um the
word Torah which is a Hebrew word for
the Bible the Old Testament it doesn't
mean knowledge which is what the word
science means in Greek science in or
Latin rather means knowledge uh and
Torah means wisdom and and teaching it
so there really are as your late great
colleague Stephen Jay gold would say
nonoverlapping magisteria they don't
necessarily have to interfere with each
other I always also point out that in
the Book of Genesis at least again I'm
not Prez again I I I consider myself a
devout agnostic uh which is which is
something I think I have in common with
the late great Freeman Jay Dyson who's a
friend of mine and a friend of my shows
many many times did he appear on it he
used to say well the existence or lack
thereof of God is a great mystery and
scientists love mysteries and we love
puzzles and maybe you can solve it maybe
it's a mystery or maybe it's a puzzle we
don't know but to give permission as you
do um to at least consider it and and
have an eminent scientist uh such as
yourself you know it's one thing if I if
I try to defend religion but someone of
your stature
defend well I'm just saying it's
delightful to have uh to that you don't
you're not scared of it and that you are
are quite um are quite comfortable but
again you're not prati this book is not
a book about uh you know why you should
believe in a particular religion uh
whatsoever so I I just want to commend
you on that I found it so refreshing and
delightful I want to talk uh just in the
last few minutes I know you're uh super
busy today uh but there are um many
Mysteries that I think are in the in the
theoretical physics world there's a
particular researcher who's a friend of
mine a friend of the show her name is
Sabine Hassen Felder she's in Germany as
a research scientist and she made a
video last week uh kind of criticizing
Lenny suskin and others and even Hawking
uh with the black hole information
Paradox claiming that in her words and
she's had nothing much good to say about
physics theoretical physics' progress in
the last 40 years according to her it's
been stagnant uh but anyway she
criticizes the black hole information
Paradox as um as the biggest overhyped
uh bit of of physics that's ever come
along I I think that's a little bit over
the top but her point is that these uh
the laws of so forth that govern this
are completely um you know kind of more
or less pedestrian and furthermore they
can't be solved because we don't know if
Hawking radiation exists and and we can
never measure it so a lot of these
things even from a fragtist point of
view are some are somewhat pointless
maybe this is relevant to what we talked
about earlier if so we don't really have
to dwell on it but um why do you think
that there is so much attention to
things like um uh like like Black Hole
uh information or the Multiverse which
will maybe close out the scientific
portion of the podcast with why is there
so much interest in that we and the
Double Split experiment epr and all
these things why does a public get so
wrapped up in this and do physicists
maybe do a disservice by by overhyping
things like this before I get to this I
think people uh who talk about topics
like black hole and so on especially
criticizing or whatever from outside
they could do that perhaps if they had a
scientific
standing and by that I mean not just to
say well I have read physics I've got my
PhD in physics therefore I can say
whatever I want I think if you have not
done sufficient research yourself in
some direction to try to criticize
somebody else I think is a little bit a
suspect so that's some of the comments
so it's like throwing throwing stone at
a building or glass or glass glass
things because you're not inside and so
that to me is a bit of a childish
reaction as far as more seriously okay
so what it is why is it that we think is
an exciting subject and so on well it's
exciting because because it was a
mystery it's still to some extent the
live a mystery and Mysteries always
guide new physics and so for us that's
the reason we study black hole of course
black hole sounds you know captures
one's imagination what if you fall in it
you know why is what if the black hole
is near us and this and that so it can
easily Captivate public but that's not
necessarily the reason we're talking
about it the reason we're talking about
is that many of the mysteries of
fundamental physics seems to be wrapped
up in it and that to us that aspect to
us is what is fascinating and yes of
course it will it will be interesting
when you want to describe what we are
doing to General Public to explain that
link because the general public can hold
on to that concept that's being
interesting because they can feel it oh
black ho that's fun that's cool that's
strange that's exotic let's see what we
have to say about it so so to say that
we are we are excited about it is not
because we want to kind of get the
public going with excitement we are
excited about it because I think many of
our deep questions are related ex Enigma
of black holes and a lot of them can be
reformulated as properties of black hole
you lose information if you throw
something into the black hole can you
figure out later on what was it that you
threw in or after the black hole
evaporates there's Z information that's
the information in other words
understanding that process tells you the
meaning of fundamental meaning of
whether or not the theory can or cannot
lose information black hole is a way to
act ask that question and that turned
out to be deeply related to many other
aspects of the theory so for us it is
that aspect now to undermine it to say
no it doesn't radiate or it doesn't
radiate we cannot measure it therefore
it's a bad question all that is again
the kind of things that it sounds like
this parallx that you mentioned this
experiment that later on was able we
were able to do but right now we cannot
do was that oh yeah are the stars really
you know far away or infinitely far away
what is it what what what is the
connection with with with with why don't
they seem to move and they indeed move
it just have no enough not enough
accuracy same with black hole if you try
to say at that time thinking about them
at finite distance and has has a meaning
is would have sounded crazy during the
Greek time perhaps to some people but we
now know that's not the right way of
asking of course the people who said
that that's a question to ask because
you cannot resolve it would have won in
the short term because yes in the short
term you cannot measure it the paralex
was not possible to measure but was it a
bad thing to raise no it wasn't a bad
thing to raise and so we have learned
that through history what we should pay
attention to and I think that uh people
who who throw stones rather than
alternatives are never the ones who
create the new science and so there's
one thing to have a a constructive Crim
of a theory to say oh you know what your
theory typically wants to have let's say
five Dimensions why not four okay let's
try to find the model why four
dimensional SpaceTime arises and so on
that's a good question and we are not
saying we have understood that but to
say oh no this is bad this is bad and so
forth without any given alternative I
think it's just this service to science
and I to be frankly frankly it's just I
think to try to uh get publicity in the
sake of from the sake of publicity to
try to say something and to me
controversial statement just to attract
attention I think is UN
I mean to be fair to her she does say
that she's written papers about the
subject herself but yeah she's yeah
certainly takes takes out a lot of uh
aggression uh but no I think it's it's
important to hear the voices as long as
you say they're acting towards a um
maybe not necessarily conciliatory you
know perspective but a congenial
perspective they're trying to do
something constructive I I agree with
that I want to uh conclude the
scientific portion just asking uh along
the lines I talked with Shelley glashow
last week and he has a wonderful book
called interactions written in 1988 and
in that book towards the end he has a
series of of questions for the future
that he suspected would be answered in
the superc conducting super collider and
and other things uh of course that
wasn't to be but the the question of uh
something like the higs he he just
assumed that we would understand the
mass no the mass of the higs not too
distant future yes we didn't learn it
from the super conducting super collider
but we found it out eventually uh and uh
but he he goes through other other
questions which in my mind are much
deeper and it was quite a treat and a
delight for me to go over this scorecard
with him and have have this eminent uh
you know Harvard Professor Boston
University give a score you know F FF
you know because some of the things that
he listed on there aside from you know
our nutrino massless which we now know
which we didn't know back then that
they're not massless at least one of
them is not massless maybe two are not
massless rather um but nevertheless why
are there three you know generations of
of quarks why are there um so many
fundamental parameters why are there so
many particles what is the uh you know
fundamental dimensions of space time
those things we we haven't really
learned much about and I'm not going to
ask you to comment on those uh there was
one or two as I said the hegs uh wasn't
even mentioned but the nutrino Mass uh
being nonzero was uh the proton lifetime
he thought you know at that time was
like 10 to the 28th years now we think
it's much bigger maybe a thousand times
longer uh and that had some implications
for super symmetry I want to ask you
your score card what would you give uh
our understanding of things like the
Multiverse uh the string landscape what
kind of grades would you give to such
subjects currently and then what kinds
of things would you want when the next
edition of uh of puzzles comes out
hopefully in 30 years after becoming an
international bestseller thank you I
think that uh the scorecard the the the
score you give to something is based on
whether or not good attempts have been
made and how much progress has been made
compared to the difficulties ahead so
when you measure it against how much
complication is on the way I would give
it A+ if you ask me if the scorecard is
to try to measure how close we are to
finally settling it I'll get it f or
very close to F so depends on what is
what is the scorecard for so we are very
far unfortunately still from making a
prediction which is really precise and
quantitative and we can say this is a
definite prediction of string theory
it's either this or the whole thing
falls apart and it's very precise we are
not there yet by far so so it depends on
that I would say that as far as the
scorecard I would give it I would view
it as what is possible to do in terms of
theoretical and huge huge things have
been learned I think to underestimate
the dualities that meaning of the
dualities that we have learned it's it's
remarkable how much we have learned for
example you mentioned this question that
Shelly raised will we know the
fundamental dimension of SpaceTime we
have learned something about this we
have learned that's a bad question why
is it a bad question we have learned
that that con that question depends on
which Viewpoint you have there is no
fundamental answer to that question it
depends on which parameter regimes you
look at so the dimension is not a
fundamental concept that even that
realization that you cannot settle that
that that question is a bad question
it's so only in one corner you can say
it's this in a different Corners is a
different number so it's not an
invariant concept those are progress so
for us we have made progresses in that
form so conceptual Pro progress is is is
what I would say is certainly has
happened hotography is another amazing
conceptual progress dualities more
generally is and so I think we are
learning quite a bit I think progress is
going to be not super fast if we are
measuring it against the yard stick of
connecting to experiments but if in
terms of what new things we have learned
is huge we have learned a huge amount
and it continues to unravel Kon thank
you I'm gonna if you have just a few
more minutes I would like to ask you
some questions I ask all of my guests on
the show is that okay sure please goad
okay great so the first one in uh in
Judaism in the Hebrew uh language
there's a concept of what's called an
ethical will and that differs from a
material will in that it is not
bequeathing monetary or material objects
to Offspring uh but instead is
bequeathing wisdom and and and
discoveries that you've made outside the
material world and it's meant to benefit
not only your biological children one of
whom put me in touch with you so I want
to thank that particular vafa son uh for
putting me in touch through the magical
medium of Twitter beyond my son yes yes
so thank him very much and when this
comes out we'll send it to him to share
uh but I want to ask you not only for
for him and his brothers but but for the
whole world what would you put in an
ethical will a a will of wisdom not only
um for your biological children but for
your ideological children of which I
count myself as one thank you H it's a
great question um I would say the
following and I was par prefaced by
saying where this wisdom may come from
it's from the realization of the
importance of duality in physics what we
have learned and I think this is a
broader
application is that the best Viewpoint
about the object depends on the question
being asked there is no best Viewpoint
and that best Viewpoint is subject to
the question so that also opens up our
mind to be
open-minded that we should not say this
is the way to look at it everything else
is bad and so on so forth we have
learned that contradictory sounding
views are sometimes necessary to
understand the subject contradictory
sounding views which are nevertheless
consistent but in a subtle way turned
out to be the beautiful aspects that
dualities have uh has shown can happen
and so in my opinion openness and the
fact that Duality shows us that
multitude of attitudes and Views is
important to appreciate and connect not
only in a scientific context but in a
broader human societal aspect I think is
a good could have a good applications
very nice so I don't know if you're a
science fiction fan but uh Shelly is a
huge science fiction fan and I asked him
uh about uh Arthur C Clark who is the
namesake of the center that I act as a
co-director um and he had uh he had
written the the book on which the movie
2001 A Space Odyssey is based so have
you seen that movie or are you like have
seen you have seen it yes good so you
might remember in that in that movie in
the opening scene there are these
primates in Africa and they discover
this Obelisk this monolith this black
ominous structure right that's placed
there and then later they don't know
what to do with that they hit it with a
bone or something and then later you see
it's on the moon and astronauts are
encountering it you know they've
obviously developed I want to ask you um
and it's sort of meant as a as a time
capsule meant to be discovered when
humanity is ready for this knowledge I
wonder if you knew you could make a
billion year long lasting Time Capsule
what would you put on it or in it what
would it what would it encapsulate I
think billion years down the line what I
would think now is probably going to be
irrelevant and so uh a one of the things
I believe in is our knowledge is
continually evolving and almost none of
the things that we think are correct now
is going to stand up to be exactly
correct there're going to be good
approximations there going to be
modifications and so on so to try to put
something so solid for future I would
feel hesitant for for for that reason if
nothing else however if you want to brag
about something we have learned in our
society in science you know you can put
some aspects of I don't know this and
that theory to to show that yeah we have
a string for example we have understood
this much of course 100,000 10,000 years
down the line they might laugh at us
okay they understood something not too
much but okay just like the way we look
at what you know scientists were doing
3,000 years ago we don't we don't think
they were really you know at The Cutting
Edge of of things now we kind of say
Okay that was fun they were smart people
but maybe not for answering this and
this and that so I'll be hesitant to to
put my word of wisdom in any form to for
the future generation I hope that they
would not laugh too hard at this that's
so although two at least two ancient
Greeks actually three ancient Greeks
Plato uh Archimedes and aristarchus make
very prominent appearances in your
delightful book yeah I this just what
you said reminds me of what Richard
Fineman said about he I didn't get to
ask him this question but he said if in
some cataclysm all scientific knowledge
were to be destroyed and only one
sentence passed on to the next
generation of creatures what statement
would contain the most information in
the fewest words I believe it is the
atomic hypothesis is that all things are
made of atoms little particles that move
around in perpetual motion attracting
each other when they are a little
distance apart but repelling barely sque
being squeezed onto one another in that
sentence you'll see an enormous amount
of information about the world if just a
little imagination and thinking are
applied and of course this is the
arthury Clark Center for human
imagination so I've managed to unify
Fineman Plato aristarchus Aristotle and
the great camon vafa who would go down
one sentence to that maybe what's that
would add maybe one little foot note to
that sentence go for it atoms and
extended objects like strings ah okay
okay that's
bald yeah as Yogi Bara said the great
prognosticator he said it's difficult to
make predictions especially about the
future ex okay the last sentence uh the
last question I ask all my guests come
on is uh relates to Arthur C Clark as
well he had these famous Three Laws one
of which was any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic he had another saying called his
second law which was that for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert and then his third law says the
only way of discovering the limits of
the possible is to venture a little way
past them into the impossible and that's
the origin of the name of my podcast I
want to ask you what advice would you
give to a young uh cuman bafa uh what
what things seemed impossible when you
were a young person but now because you
had cour
and you went into the impossible now
seems doable to you and if only in
hindsight to me math was always always a
attractive the ideas of the MTH hanging
together the be beauty of ukian geometry
understanding relation of simple objects
and I also was always fascinated by you
know things around us like you know how
how does the whole thing work what why
there are atoms how does this work and
that work and this one and these two
things sounded to me like separate un
universes like math ukian geometry and
so on is there and then you have this
real world that's around us has nothing
a priority to this math to try to bring
these two universes together or closer
first of all I noticed not only that
there are already big lengths between
them through centuries of work when I
got to learn more but then I felt could
they become even closer and in fact
indispensable for one another and so
when in the context of strength Theory
the two have come together in such a way
that you cannot do one without the other
you cannot do physics without math and
now also you cannot do math without
physics so the fact that these things
can be combined is something that is
really pleasurable for me in terms of my
own interest but I think anybody has
their own interest and I hope that they
don't they everybody follows what they
are deeply passionate about and you know
there are things which are fashionable
today or may not be fashionable tomorrow
and so forth but whatever you're excited
by if you follow it regardless of being
fashionable or not fashionable gives you
pleasure and usually by that action
you're thinking deeply about it you will
convey something important to the rest
so I think follow your dreams is is a
cliche but I think is a correct cliche
in this case yes and as you say in the
beginning of the book you dedicate it to
your parents um as well as your family
uh Simeon and Javad for nurturing your
curiosity and I think that's so uh
delightful that you uh have now shared
this curious uh
investigator uh perspective that you
bring you you're a towering figure in
science and and I I really appreciate
your time I have to go now to paint uh
the surface of Gabriel's horn um it's
going to keep me busy right yes it will
a very very long time maybe time but it
was pleasure Brian to talk with you and
the the very enjoyable uh discussion and
questions thank you for having me on
your podcast